the kidneys are located on either side
of the spinal column in the posterior
abdominal cavity behind the peritoneum
in the retr peronal
space the functions of each kidney
include filtration of metabolic wastes
fluids and electrolytes from the blood
during urine
production stimulation of red blood cell
production and regulation of blood
pressure the medular pyramid and outer
cortex compose the renal lobe the
structural unit of the kidney branches
of the renal artery Supply each renal
lobe the functional unit of the kidney
is the nefron composed of the renal
Corpus and the renal
tubule the renal corpal is where initial
blood filtration
occurs it consists of a spherical
network of capillaries called the
glomerulus enclosed by a cup-shaped
structure called Bowman's capsule the
size difference between the afrine
arterial and the efferent arterial of
the glomerulus creates the pressure
that forces glomular filtrate into
Bowman's
capsule reabsorption of water and other
substances occurs in the renal
tubule 99% of the glomerular filtrate is
reabsorbed as it passes through the
parts of the renal tubule including the
proximal convoluted
tubule Loop of Henley
distal convoluted tubule and collecting
duct acute renal failure is the sudden
loss of the kidney's ability to remove
waste and concentrate urine pre-renal
acute renal failure causes include
anything that compromises blood flow to
the kidneys
such as Hemorrhage or
hypotension singularly or together
reduce blood pressure and reduced blood
volume at the glomerulus result in less
filtrate moving into Bowman's
capsule intrarenal acute renal failure
results from damage to nephrons toxins
and lack of oxygen to kidney tissues can
damage the nefron postrenal acute renal
failure is associated with urinary tract
obstructions such as kidney
stones treatment for acute renal failure
depends on the cause maintaining blood
fluid volume
hemodialysis or surgical removal of
kidney tract obstructions may be
required chronic renal failure is the
loss of kidney function over a period of
years nefron function is lost as a
result of systemic diseases such as
hypertension and diabetes meltis or
kidney diseases such as chronic
glomerulo
nephritis treatments include dietary
control including fluid
restrictions medication for the
underlying condition and electrolyte
modifiers ACE inhibitors for
hypertension and Insulin therapy or
hemodialysis can reduce chronic renal
failure end stage renal failure usually
requires dialysis and kidney
transplantation